we'll start the show in just a second
but first i want to tell you about
today's
sponsors steadymd lets you maintain a
meaningful long-lasting relationship
with a primary care physician
who you can meet with anytime over phone
or video chat you don't need insurance
it's only 99
a month with no other fees or copays
visit steadymd.com
pacman to get started blinkist is the
app that helps you become a more
well-rounded person by letting you read
or listen to an entire
nonfiction book in just 15 minutes you
can try it for free
and get 25 percent off a subscription by
going to blinkist.com
david pakman hydrant is the delicious
fruit drink powder
packed with essential electrolytes for
hydration
and it's more cost effective than
expensive sugary sports drinks
to get 25 percent off go to drink
hydrant.com
pacman and use the code pacman all right
i want to
sort of get ahead of this story and
spend some time today
talking about supposed biden mask
mandates because the amount of
disinformation that we're already seeing
if it's at all a preview
is going to absolutely explode when joe
biden is actually
sworn in as president of the united
states on january 20th
so to go back a little bit right-wingers
have been warning even during the
campaign
joe biden will lock everyone in their
homes joe biden will be a dictator with
masks and all sorts of other things if
he becomes president
and over the last 48 to 72 hours we
heard two different things that are not
the same thing very important
we heard from dr anthony fauci that
indeed joe biden plans to do
a hundred day mask initiative and within
that
there will be a piece that is a federal
mass mandate now
when you hear federal mass mandate many
people imagine something that is very
different
from what we're actually going to get so
let me say this in the clearest
terms possible joe biden nor
any president can mandate
a national mask wearing law
where everybody's forced to wear a mask
outside of their homes i've already
addressed this so listen
very closely to what i'm going to say
what joe biden can do
is address the nation from the oval
office and
ask people to wear masks he can call the
governors
of 50 states and ask them to put in
place mass mandates which governors
can do in various areas massachusetts
governor charlie baker is an example
earlier this week he's a republican
announced that
there will be a mass mandate in
workplaces in massachusetts we got an
email
from our office tenant where everybody's
working from home anyway right now but
they said
everybody's got to wear a mask per
charlie baker's order
governors can do that given states
rights and yet there's a ton of
headlines
today which are very confusing in
talking about a joe biden
nationwide mask mandate suggesting
the federal government will force
everybody to wear a mask so let me
explain what's going on
as the president of the united states
part of the
a federal government joe biden plans to
issue
a mask mandate that includes federal
buildings
as well as airplanes trains and buses
which are regulated by the
federal department of transportation
that's it
that's the mandate that's what the
president can do via executive order and
in just about every state
masks are already required in all of
those places now i do have
some federal government employee friends
who work in red states who have told me
you know the the equivalent agency in
massachusetts and in california
you've got to wear a mask in my office
for that same agency in a red state
our boss has not mandated masks that
will change
based on this mask mandate for federal
buildings but it will change very little
else
so before we go crazy misstating what
this is
joe biden's mandate will apply only to
federal buildings
and transportation vehicles regulated by
the d.o.t beyond that any mass
guidelines from biden will merely be
guidelines they will be
requests they will be proposals it will
be up to your governor to decide what to
do
that's it now dr fauci has said
wearing masks for 100 days is a good
idea it will be up to the people and
governors
ultimately to decide what it is they
want to do for people who have been
wearing masks for months already
this is going to be much ado about
nothing consider that you know there is
now a light at the end of the tunnel
let's actually work together to start
getting past this if we can start here's
my trajectory
if we can start vaccinating five to
seven percent of our population each
month
maybe that includes december maybe we
only get
you know one two percent done in
december in january we get five to seven
percent
february etc this means in six months we
could have somewhere between 30 and 42
of the population vaccinated plus the 5
to 10 percent who will have recovered
from the virus
we don't yet know how uniform
immunity is when you recover there's the
idea
that if you have a very light case your
immunity may not be as robust as if you
recover from a more serious case so we
don't know exactly
but we could be heading towards a
roughly 50 level of immunity by may 1st
maybe by may 15th
that won't be the end but it will be a
dramatically better situation
we will also likely at that point have
cheap
at-home tests so like for me if i
imagine hey i might be able to order
50 or 100 of these cheap at home rapid
tests
i've been very cautious but i've
continued going to the grocery store i
go to the post office during the summer
i was hanging out outdoors with friends
eating outdoors at restaurants if we had
on may 15th may 1st may 15th
50 immunity and these at home tests i
would likely be ready to say for example
hey here's a group of six friends
we've all been working from home if we
all do a rapid test
i would be comfortable if we're all
negative hanging out indoors maintaining
a reasonable amount of distance
uh assuming we're at 50 immunity with
these tests okay i mean listen it's it's
it's not perfect but we're talking about
may june and to be clear with half the
country vaccinated now you also have to
remember
there is a lag time on vaccination
immunity
and what i mean by that is the time
until vaccinated people
actually reduce the number of deaths
could is is weeks and what i mean by
that is
on day one you get dose number one dose
number one confers
some immunity but not all so that starts
to have an effect
day 22 21 days later you get your second
dose
and then seven days after that you would
be considered to be
you know there's a 95 chance that you
were immune so by day
28 to 29 you
ideally are no longer
getting other people sick who you might
have gotten sick were you not vaccinated
since it takes 20 days in general from
when someone
catches the virus to when they die if
they're going to die
vaccinated individuals will not be
fully effective at reducing deaths
for 48 days we won't see the impact on
deaths of a vaccinated individual
for up to 48 days now we know that after
dose one you can be as much as 70 or
even 75
percent likely to to be immune so these
are all
confidence intervals but i think you
understand the point that there's a lag
time um before which
vaccination uh is not really doing doing
that much
to stop cases and to stop death so the
the point is this is a process
and it there is every indication that by
may 1 may 15
we will be in a better situation masks
will likely be required in just as many
places as they are today
uh but we are now we had 2 960 people
die yesterday were
essentially at a 9 11 every day so
rather than
the point is rather than lying about
what joe biden plans to do
let's work together and start getting
past this i'm going to tell you right
now
about one of the most disgusting abuses
of police
power that we have seen in a while
in terms of an anecdotal individual
story
back on may 20th i brought you the story
of rebecca jones from florida
she is the scientist who used to run the
florida kova dashboard and back in may
she was fired as she put it because she
refused to manipulate the data to make
it look better
in florida republican governor ron
desantis made the decision in florida to
open up
really early before it made sense and
she was told
she claims to censor data change other
data make
it seem as though the premature opening
in florida
was not actually premature she wasn't
willing to do it she says that's why she
was fired
this week rebecca jones's home was
raided in a style raid we have video of
the raid we're showing it to our
television audience police burst in
shouting pointing guns
why were they there at all police were
serving a search warrant
against rebecca jones for a suspected
computer crime
what is that crime well remember she was
fired for ref
she says she was fired for refusing to
manipulate kova data
the allegation is that after she was
fired and therefore was no longer a
florida state
employee she logged onto the government
messaging system
meant only for employees of the state of
florida to send a message to her
co-workers
that she was asked to modify the data
and is refusing to do so
and for that alleged crime of sending a
message
she was on the receiving end of a
militarized police raid of her home
jones by the way denies that she even
did that she says
no i i went public i you know wrote an
op-ed
in the miami herald i um spoke publicly
but i i didn't even do the thing i'm
accused of doing so the immediate
suspicion
was that this came from the top that
republican governor ron desantis was
behind all of it desantis has denied
involvement but now the part that's
becoming the focus
is that the raid was carried out in an
obviously absurd way it's completely
indefensible how this was done
police burst in with weapons as jones is
crying she's yelling that there's kids
in the house that her husband is in the
house
and jones even says police pointed guns
at her kids
police deny that they pointed guns at
her kids police are saying
listen jones took a while to answer the
door that escalated the level
of aggressiveness that we used and the
problem here
is that the the problem is the paradigm
of the raid at all
what is tantamount to a swat team
showing up
because someone is suspected of using an
employee-only messaging system to send a
message
we can have a bigger debate about if and
whether militar militarized police raids
should be used for search warrants at
all
but the debate would be confined to
people suspected of violent crimes
high-level crimes people who are uh uh
believed to be uh risks of some kind or
something else
almost no one with any semblance of
common sense would even say
let's debate whether an alleged crime
like this
warrants a militarized police search
warrant serving it's ridiculous and it's
the worst of the worst of the overuse of
police power
now the individual level uh at the
individual level the officers themselves
don't appear to have done anything wrong
certainly that will be provable in terms
of
you know they pointed guns at my kids
police say they didn't you know unless
there's video of that
my point is not to excuse the officer's
individual but to explain that
they announced themselves they secured
people in the house
they they roughly followed protocol in
these militarized raids the problem is
that such a raid took place at all
the orders were from whoever decided
that this was the suspect then were
going in guns blazing
and the problem of course is that the
decision to execute this
in that way was made that's the problem
and the suspicion
of course is this was retribution
against rebecca jones
because she refused to falsify covet
data back in may
to say that this is over policing is not
even a strong enough phrase if we
saw this in another country we would all
be saying
this is an authoritarian strong-arming
of a whistleblower to intimidate them
for exposing
that very government that went after
them if we saw it elsewhere that's what
we would be saying
let me know your thoughts i want to hear
from you i'm on twitter
deepak the david pakman show at
[Music]
davidpakman.com
if you are anything like me you probably
aren't thrilled with the idea of going
into
a doctor's office right now and
thankfully there is a
practical and affordable way to take
control of your health
and get personalized care from the
comfort of your home it's a service
called
steady md they're one of our sponsors
you take a quiz
you get matched with a licensed primary
care physician
who understands your health needs you
have a one hour video call with your new
doctor
you establish a meaningful relationship
with them and after that
your doctor is available to you anytime
by text phone or video chat this is not
a random doctor on call
each doctor at steady md has a limited
number of patients so they actually have
time
to listen to you you get the personal
attention that you deserve
they can do almost everything an
in-person doctor can do
perform medical evaluations talk to you
about health concerns
send prescriptions to your home or local
pharmacy
and anything they can't do online
they'll quickly set you up with
an in-person provider to do things like
blood tests as an example
you don't need insurance it's only 99
bucks a month with
no other fees or copays there are so
many
practical advantages to using steady md
for primary care
and it's also so much more affordable
go to steadymd.com pacman to take the
free quiz
see which doctor is right for you i took
their quiz they matched me with
a doctor who specializes in my
particular health needs and situation
the doctor they gave me
is a really perfect fit for me and my
medical needs there's no risk no
commitment to get started
just click the link right underneath
this video
[Music]
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
the david pakman show depends primarily
on folks like you listeners viewers who
get a membership
at joinpacman.com consider yourselves
invited
you will get access to the daily bonus
show and extra show for our members
every day
and you can sign up in mere moments at
joinpakman.com we do have a coupon code
available that coupon code is
fresh start if you would like a discount
you can use the code don't feel
obligated
but either way you can sign up at
joinpakman.com
the hatred mail continues to fly in fast
and furious quick reminder what is
hatred mail
take your mask and shove it now
let me tell you about my fake medical
condition
patriot mail written by patriots who
hate
david pakman because america
and because freedom
all right so i really need your help
in figuring out what on earth this
week's hatred
is talking about what what on earth are
they accusing me of take a listen to
this
david pakman is a frustrated loser
a clueless out of touch beta gamma male
someone who didn't develop socially in a
proper way
and who now has a chip on his shoulder
you're a loser david
even though you have a million
subscribers
david pakman is a very easily triggered
beta male
whose personality i can recognize from
losers at school growing up
he used the name of a donator who
happened to be a jew
david pakman is a
what does this even mean he uh he used
a name of a donator who happened to be
jewish like is
is the allegation that my name isn't
really david pakman
but i've i've adopted the name david
pakman on the show
because it's the name of a different
jewish person i don't
i really don't understand this and gamma
male i've never heard
like i'm guessing gamma male is worse
than even beta male
um and of course that's very inaccurate
i've always considered myself an epsilon
male to be totally frank you can you can
check with people who know me they will
commit to that
epsilon male is much more appropriate so
listen the way
to fight hatredism is uh
very simple use the coupon code hatred
40
when you sign up on my website
joinpakman.com
and whenever the code hatred 40 is used
you save 40 off of a membership
and the hatreds cry they're just bawling
they're they're tear the tears won't
stop flowing and
they're maggoteers to be perfectly frank
the coupon code
is h-a-t-r-i-o-t-4-0
so i believe that we are getting closer
to the beginning of the middle
of the natural end of donald trump's
continued
unhinged baseless efforts to overturn
the results of the 2020 presidential
election
donald trump and others have continued
to insist
this is going to the supreme court the
supreme court is going to decide and the
supreme court is going to do all sorts
of great things for donald trump
and he will win and he will get another
term
well the supreme court has finally
weighed in for the first time
and they have uh refused to block
pennsylvania from formalizing the
victory of joe biden
now as i'm sure you've heard by now even
without pennsylvania
if through some completely unimaginable
circumstance pennsylvania went to trump
which it's not going to
even without pennsylvania joe biden
would still win joe biden has 306
electoral votes
pennsylvania's worth 20. if you take
those away from joe biden he still wins
with 286 electoral votes that's 16 more
than the 270 that are required but the
point here
is with five days left
until the official electoral vote is
cast on december 14th
the supreme court shows absolutely no
interest and no willingness to get
involved in holding this up in any way
this was sort of well one of the last
ditch
efforts so that you understand the
argument that was used
republican congressman mike kelly filed
the lawsuit claiming
that when pennsylvania expanded mail-in
voting in 2019
it was illegal under state law that was
the legal complaint that sort of worked
its way through the system
since the election the court very
briefly uh
wrote a rejection notice they were asked
to throw out the absentee ballots they
said we're not going to do that
they just said no there were no noted
dissents from a single justice on the
court
notice also that the arguments they've
been making
about why this election was unfair
ranged
dramatically in some states the problem
is they counted the same ballots many
times they alleged these are all
unproven allegations some states same
ballots counted many many times
other states republican observers
weren't allowed to observe
other states expanding vote by mail was
illegal
other states sending supposedly
unsolicited ballots
was fraudulent in some way other states
someone hid and then pulled out
duffel bags of ballots from the ceiling
or from under a table or wherever they
came from
in some states dead people voted in
others people voted twice
etc etc and every single one of these
claims
in court have not stood up and it
actually
that it's not even accurate to say that
in court
they very often don't even make these
claims it's really common that you'll
see a trump lawyer on tv
say one thing happened when they filed
the legal complaint to the court
they don't make the same argument often
because they know there's no evidence of
it
yesterday also a michigan federal court
denied
a republican attempt to preserve
election data and machines
for some kind of future inspection so we
are having a situation in which these
lame attempts to overturn the election
results
they're kind of naturally winding down
donald trump's two primary lawyers on
this rudy giuliani and jenna ellis
they both now have coronavirus we'll
talk about jenna ellis's
diagnosis a little bit later rudy
supposedly is
going to be appearing at some events
remotely from his hospital room
but trump has now lost more than 50
legal challenges
we're five days from the formal
electoral vote and donald trump
reportedly
might be heading to florida for vacation
soon there are suspicions he won't even
return to the white house so
slowly but surely without anybody at any
point
saying it's over uh people on trump's
side i mean
we've been we've called this a month ago
and so did
media outlets and states have certified
but slowly but surely
this entire thing is going to kind of
evaporate and
on the basis of california now
certifying their election biden
has formally won more than 270 electoral
votes the the very final step
is for that electoral vote to actually
take place on december 14th where the
electors designated by each state say
we cast our electoral votes uh for joe
biden or for donald trump depending on
the state that that they are in so
we're five days from that and i think it
will be over at that point
although who knows maybe some will keep
insisting that joe biden won't be sworn
in
on january 20th he will that's it
and we'll have more cover coverage of
this on our instagram page you can
follow us on instagram at
davidpakmanshow
and of course follow me on instagram at
david.pacman as well
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
what if you could read 10 books in just
one sitting that's exactly
what one of my favorite apps lets you do
it's called blinkist and what they do is
take
thousands of popular nonfiction books
they condense them down
into text or audio that you can consume
in 15 minutes
blinkist makes sure that you're getting
all of the
important core insights from each book
so it's perfect for exploring a book you
otherwise wouldn't have time for
if there's a full book you're thinking
about buying you can use blinkist to get
a sample
first just think how much you can enrich
yourself
by being able to soak up an entire
nonfiction book
in just 15 minutes i recently read a
brief history of time of course by the
great
stephen hawking this is a book that i
have been aware of for so long
and other things got in the way and it
was fantastic
to check it out on blinkist blinkist has
books on politics philosophy
science they have 27 different
non-fiction categories and a
subscription is only about eight bucks a
month
and you get the entire library but
you can try it totally free and get 25
off a subscription when you go to
blinkist.com
david pakman i've put the link right
underneath this video
welcome back to the david pakman show
yesterday on the show i told you that
coronavirus vaccine manufacturers
pfizer and moderna rightly turned down
an invitation from donald trump to go to
this propaganda event at the white house
which they call the vaccine summit and
it is
it's a really good thing that pfizer and
moderna did turn that down
because it was completely humiliating
and embarrassing and donald trump simply
could not contain himself once again
blurting out seemingly uncontrollably
that he won when he took
questions having nothing whatever to do
with vaccinations so
let's go through this and you will
quickly notice that donald trump
although he likely
realizes that joe biden will be
president on january 20th he still can't
accept that he
simply lost and this is exactly the
behavior we would predict from
narcissists like donald trump this is
exactly what they would struggle with
so we'll start with the wackiest moment
which is when donald trump was
confronted with the reality that
the next administration joe biden's
administration
they will be overseeing most of the
vaccine distribution
and wouldn't it make sense to involve
them in this discussion and trump
just can't help himself and he blurts
out
he won you know he won check it out
and he sort of tries to stay on track
but he falls apart with lies about
stealing the election
just the humiliating answer the next
administration will be the one
ultimately that implements a lot of the
distribution of this vaccine will
oversee
much of the future of the way operation
warp speed goes forward why not include
members of the biden transition team
as part of this summit that you're
hosting today well we're going to have
to see who the next administration is
because we won in those swing states and
uh there was uh terrible things that
went on so we're gonna have to see who
the next administration is but
whichever the next administration is
will
really benefit by what we've been able
to do with this
incredible science the doctors all of
the people that came up the lab
technicians the work
the work that's been done is incredible
and it will be incredible for the next
administration
and hopefully the next administration
will be the trump administration
because you can't steal hundreds of
thousands of votes
you can't have fraud and deception and
all of the things that they did
and then slightly win a swing state and
you just have to look at the numbers
look at what's been on tape look at all
the corruption
and we'll see you can't win an election
like that so hopefully the next
administration
will be the trump administration a
continuation which has led us to the
highest stock markets we've ever had the
best employment numbers we've ever had
a rebuilt military if you look at
the tax reductions are the greatest in
history the regulation reduction's the
greatest in history
it leads us to space force which nobody
thought was possible
all of the things we've done and we were
rewarded with a victory now let's see
whether or not somebody has the courage
whether it's a legislator or
legislatures
or whether it's a justice of the supreme
court or a number of justices of the
supreme court
let's see if they have the courage to do
what everybody in this country knows
is right i received almost 75 million
votes the highest number of votes in the
history of our country for a sitting
president
so that's two minutes of cuckoo off the
wall stuff
i'm not going to go through all of it
but as you can see donald trump
cannot accept his loss he still is
telling
lies after lies after lies about the
election
trump then falsely claimed plainly
that it would take five to six years to
make a vaccine normally were it not for
trump
thanks to operation warp speed he did it
in nine months
and then later he says you know without
operation warp speed
it could take infinity to make a vaccine
before operation warp speed the typical
time frame for development
that approval as you know uh could be
infinity
now as i've told you before but it bears
repeating the reason that the pfizer
moderna and astrazeneca oxford vaccines
were developed quickly
both in and out of the u.s understand
that the timeline was identical in and
out of the u.s
regardless of operation warp speed is
it's a different type of vaccine this
it's a vaccine that works on an mrna
platform rather than a live or weakened
virus
it has nothing to do with trump it's
science it's a type of vaccine that's
faster to develop
i mentioned yesterday that donald trump
failed to secure
possibly 100 million doses of the
vaccine offered to him by pfizer in late
summer we're going to talk about this
more later
but now donald trump is trying to hide
this by talking about an executive order
listen to this
we're working with the world we have
great companies and we're working with
the world in just a few minutes i'll
sign an executive order to ensure that
the united states government
prioritizes the getting out of the
vaccine to american citizens before
sending it to
other nations now if necessary i told
you we'll
invoke the defense production act so
what trump is doing here because he
failed to simply say yes give us the
doses
he now realizes there's going to be a
supply issue since
pfizer sold the doses trump turned down
to other countries so trump has come up
with an executive order he's going to
sign
it's not clear at all that the executive
order will do a damn thing
it's not clear how it would be enforced
it's not clear who would enforce it it's
not clear how it gets us a single
additional dose
trump failed again but he has this
executive order idea which we'll talk
about more later
and then trump i guess struggling with
language and physics
saying cases will soon skyrocket
downwards listen to that the numbers
should
skyrocket downward i guess he means
cases will soon burrow down deep into
the ground very very low
strange language to be using and then
trump actually took some questions
he was asked about we have holidays
upcoming
we how do you want people to be safe
vaccines won't be widely rolled out
until next year
and trump seems to refer to approaching
herd immunity because of what he claims
are 15 percent of people
who got the virus and recovered it's a
very weird moment
i'm wondering what your message is for
the american people
given all the increasing cases right now
about what they should do over christmas
and the hardship that they're all facing
this fire does get worse yeah well cdc
puts out
their guidelines and the very important
guidelines but uh i think this i think
that the vaccine was
our goal that was number one because
that was the way
uh that was the way it ends plus you do
have an immunity you develop immunity
over a period of time and
i hear we're close to 15 i'm hearing
that and that
is terrific that's a very powerful
vaccine in itself so the president
seems to be saying there 15 of the
country already got the virus and
they've recovered so they're immune so
we have 15
immunity right now this is a dangerous
claim for a few reasons number one
officially we've only had 15 and a half
million cases
minus nearly 300 000 that died meaning
we have about 15.2 million people we
know about
who uh either have recovered or have the
virus now
most of whom will survive that's under
five percent of the population
when trump says 15 have had it and
recovered
it's possible that for every case we
know about there's
two point something more that we don't
know about that would mean
you know about 50 million people have
had the virus it could be a stretch
we don't know but the really dangerous
part is we don't know
whether every recovered patient is
equally immune or how long that natural
immunity lasts
it's possible that most of those light
or asymptomatic cases
may not have the same immunity that
somebody who had symptoms and a more
serious case and recovered does
we just don't know so as usual trump is
clueless
and he's airing rather than on the side
of caution he's airing on the side of
belligerence
later trump was asked why the white
house is holding in-person parties
with hundreds of people violating the
cdc guidelines and trump says
well listen these are christmas parties
officials here in this room have
encouraged americans
not to travel this holiday season not to
go to large gatherings
across the street you've been holding
holiday parties with
hundreds of people many not wearing
masks why are you
modeling a different behavior to the
american people and what you're trying
to tell
well they're christmas parties and
frankly we've reduced the number of
earth substantially as you know
and i see a lot of people at the parties
wearing masks i mean i have i would say
that
i look out at the audience at those
parties we have a lot of people wearing
masks
and i think that's a good thing oh right
a christmas party if it's christmas then
i guess you're protected somehow it's
different than
you know hanukkah party or super bowl
party
that's different these are christmas
parties after all there are
indoor events with literally hundreds of
people and then
lastly here trump calls
for judges and republican legislators
to have what he calls the courage to
help him
overthrow the election results unable
to accept what has taken place here
i received almost 75 million votes the
highest number of votes in the history
of our country for a sitting president
12 million more than the 63 million we
received
four years ago president obama received
3 million less
in his second term and he won easily i
received 12 million more which by the
way is a record
12 million more and they say
that when the numbers came out and the
numbers came through machines and all of
those ballots were taken away
and added all you have to do is turn on
your local television set and you'll see
what happened
so another embarrassing shameful
destructive q and a session for donald
trump
and as we continue to move towards
the end of the year holiday christmas
hanukkah starting very soon
very much looking forward to it um we
are increasingly hearing rumors that
donald trump is sort of going to just
go to florida and maybe never come back
to washington d.c
he'll just kind of disappear he may
never concede he may not be at the
inauguration he may just kind of be gone
and then maybe start campaigning for
2024 still a question mark
but i don't anticipate too many more of
these q a sessions
let's now focus in on this vaccine
executive order that i mentioned earlier
you really have to see this next clip i
already told you yesterday and we just
discussed
in our previous clip donald trump's
vaccine
executive order that he signed at
yesterday's vaccine summit which
we don't understand donald trump's
executive order
says that the u.s government will work
to secure
coronavirus vaccine doses for the united
states
before other countries get them now it's
not
really clear what the enforcement
of that would be it's not clear what
enforcement is even legally possible
it's not clear what authority the united
states has to obtain vaccines for us
before
other countries get them we weren't the
only ones confused by this executive
order and yesterday
donald trump's vaccine chief who i'm
actually
more or less happy with he's been doing
a relatively good job
at not politicizing the vaccine program
he's seemed immune for lack of a better
term
uh to pressure from pressure to say
things that he doesn't believe i'm
talking about dr monseff slowly
he was interviewed by abc's george
stephanopoulos yesterday and you have to
see this
george stephanopoulos says to him what
is trump's vaccine
executive order about like what does it
do and slowly doesn't even pretend he
just says i have no idea whatsoever he
just sort of
shrugs and raises his eyebrows he has no
this is trump's vaccine chief no idea
what trump's executive order is about
check it out it's like a greek tragedy
can you explain this executive order the
president is going to be putting out i
don't quite understand he's saying that
foreign countries aren't going to be
able to get the vaccine until everybody
here in the united states
guess that it sounds like the problem is
the opposite right now pfizer has made
deals with other countries that are
going to limit the supply here
frankly i don't know and frankly i'm
staying out of this so i can't comment
i don't i don't know
but you're the chief science advisor for
operation warp speed
our work is is you know rolling we have
plans we feel that we can deliver the
vaccines as needed so
i don't know exactly what what this
order is about
just amazing optics slowly
just washing his hands of this all
together i have no idea
i'm not involved in it not even
pretending to try to explain it but the
key
thing here is actually what george
stephanopoulos says
which is the problem is the opposite
trump signing an executive order saying
get us vaccines before other countries
thanks to trump turning down a hundred
million vaccine doses in the late summer
other countries are going to get vaccine
doses before us the uk
already vaccinating people as one
example so
the the back story again if you missed
yesterday's show i'll quickly remind you
trump was offered back in late summer
the opportunity to get 100 million more
doses of the pfizer vaccine secured for
the united states and trump said no
and so pfizer went and sold those doses
to other countries as they would
obviously do and that includes the uk
and some european union countries have
also secured
vaccines now we've learned that thanks
to that decision
the us is not likely to get a second
tranche of the pfizer vaccine doses
until june of 2021. this is just
because trump turned down 100 million
doses so trump is now panicking
and he put together this completely
flaccid impotent executive order which
appears to do nothing other than
maybe make it look like he's doing
something to cover up that failure
from the summer when he could simply
have said yeah we'll take the doses of
course
and now you have vaccine chief dr monsef
slowly on national tv saying
i have no idea what that is that is
about washing his hands completely and
saying i'm not involved
now one interesting thing is that you
can tell
fear of trump is palpably waning as
trump gets closer and closer to being an
ex-president
slowly himself might have answered this
question the same way at any point
but in total when you look at other
republicans and other people
ancillary to the trump administration
they seem more and more willing to just
say things as they are
rather than bending over backwards the
way we saw them do for so long to
pretend that
what trump is saying and doing makes
even an iota of sense
now as far as the executive order it
again
feels sort of like when donald trump's
dad fred trump was suffering from
dementia and he'd go to his office and
he would
uh die call people on his phone but the
phone would only go to his secretary
and he would shuffle around stacks of
paper and sign things that were
completely meaningless
as if he was working nobody's really
paying attention anymore
and trump's executive order it does
nothing it's not even clear
what the enforcement would or could
possibly be we're getting into a very
strange kind of lame duck period with
donald trump and as a reminder
six weeks we have six weeks i believe to
the day right i think january 20th is a
wednesday
i believe we are six weeks to the day
uh of all of this all of this ending and
we will all be much better for it let's
take a quick break make sure
you are following the show on facebook
facebook.com davidpakmanshow
we will talk about jenna ellis now
having the virus and i have a bunch of
other things to discuss with you
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
[Music]
one of our sponsors is hydrant which is
a delicious
fruit drink powder that you mix into
water for rehydration and they're giving
you 25
off your first order it's made with four
key
electrolytes that the body needs
powerfully supporting your hydration
hydrant tastes great it's made with real
fruit juice it's been a great part of my
daily routine for a while now
keeping myself hydrated puts me in a
better mood
the body needs hydration for basic
energy and focus and hydrant is the
perfect way to rehydrate
especially because it's cost effective
and lower in sugar compared to all of
those popular
sports drinks that are out there you
really have to try it for yourself to
see what i mean
it tastes great they also have a variety
called hydrant immunity
packed with vitamins a b c and d
which is also very much worth trying
hydrant has a full refund guarantee if
you're not satisfied and you'll get 25
percent off your first order when you go
to drink hydrant.com
pacman or just enter the code pacman at
checkout
i've put the link right underneath this
video
the david pakman show at davidpakman.com
so earlier this week uh donald trump's
attorney rudy giuliani tested positive
for coronavirus and now another trump
attorney jenna
ellis has tested positive as well these
are the primary two trump lawyers who
have been waging this completely
pointless and bogus baseless war
to overturn the election results based
on imaginary
voter fraud jonathan swann from
axios reporting on the story tweeting
that president trump's lawyer
jenna ellis has informed associates she
has coronavirus
multiple sources tell axio stirring west
wing fears
after she attended a senior staff
christmas party on friday
so a few different things here number
one is this surprising no
you know that she's not been taking
precautions she's not been staying home
she's not been avoiding indoor crowds
she's not been wearing a mask
um she and rudy giuliani have been
flying around the country
daily in a pandemic since the election
during the worst period we've had since
the beginning of the pandemic
and also attending at least jenna ellis
did
a white house party and other larger
events they're frequently maskless at
these so-called hearings and events so
rudy got it
jenna got it and now there's panic at
the white house because she was with a
huge swath of white house staffers on
friday and that may end up becoming
another one of these super spreader
events
she reportedly had no mask there and
it's all a complete and total mess
now of course i wish no one ill
i hope she recovers even though she's
part of the problem i'd never wish
illness or death upon anyone
what i want to mention is that there is
something sort of poetic
about the virus that they ignored
and didn't deal with now shutting down
their hair-brained ill-advised attempts
to overturn
the results of an election that donald
trump simply lost partially
because of his his mishandling of the
virus
by infecting his legal team i'm not
saying it's karma i'm not saying it's
divine intervention i'm just saying
there's something
ironic poetic whatever that part of the
reason trump lost
is his mishandling of the virus that
same virus is now what is going to
interfere
with trump making a legal case that he
should be the winner anyway despite
having lost
now that rudy is sidelined jenna ellis's
sideline
does this sort of naturally force
the voter fraud nonsense the hearings
the legal filings to kind of peter out
or are they going to try to push it
remotely
via zoom one report is that rudy
sometime this week
is going to be joining another one of
these hearings remotely from his
hospital room now by the way
that's a whole other issue um some
leaked i guess you would call them
exchanges between rudy giuliani
and trump's doctor have been reported on
and the allegation is that
trump's doctor called rudy and said rudy
go to the hospital when rudy tested
positive
and rudy said i feel fine why would i
don't i don't want to go to the hospital
and trump's doctor reportedly told rudy
listen rudy
just go we can get this dealt with in
three days by giving you the same
treatment trump got and presumably what
this means is
if you take someone and you monitor them
immediately
you monitor their oxygen levels you
scan them regularly at the sign of any
decreased
uh and any type of any concerning
vital sign you immediately deal with
that
so that the body can continue fighting
the virus there's no question
is the point that if everybody could get
the treatment that trump got and that
now rudy giuliani is getting just by hey
i'm going to check myself into a
hospital and get
top treatments and best doctors and all
of that way more people would survive
and we know that intuitively
and it appears as though they're saying
it to rudy in uncertain terms we can
deal with this in three days if we do
what we did
with donald trump and monitoring you for
72 hours wouldn't probably apply to
everybody
but it would save a lot of lives if
everybody could could get that but
coronavirus causing the end of this
absurd campaign to overturn the results
of an election that trump lost in part
because he ignored the virus early on
that really is something i mean you know
what they said was 15 cases that would
soon be zero back in april
has now infected trump trump's son don
jr
trump's other son baron trump uh don
jr's girlfriend kimberly guilfoyle
trump's personal personal lawyer his
campaign lawyer his press secretary a
bunch of republican senators and on and
on and on and i caught a discussion on
right wing
uh on in a right-wing internet forum
yesterday
where right-wingers were suspicious
about
why is it that when prominent democrats
get the virus it isn't
covered by the so-called fake news media
now the reason for that is that it's
mostly prominent republicans that are
getting the virus because democrats are
taking the virus more seriously
imagine at this point at this stage of
the game
having the lack of ability to reflect on
something like that
and coming away with the idea that they
the media covers up prominent democratic
covet cases no
it's that it's mostly prominent
republicans getting it
because they're doing things like what
rudy giuliani and
and jenna ellis have been doing and
people wondering is she going to get
the same privilege as rudy and getting
checked into a top-notch hospital for
observation as a precaution
chris christie was able to do it of
course trump was able to do it i have no
idea
but what i can tell you for sure is that
so many americans
would have survived the virus had
they been able to do the same thing
many of whom were behaving far more
responsibly than rudy giuliani and jenna
ellis i mean
tragically um there are people who
wear a mask every time they leave their
home work from home
do nothing other than go to the grocery
store and they've gotten the virus and
some of them have died
they didn't have access to this type of
treatment rudy giuliani flies around the
country
waging a bogus voter fraud case shutting
down the arizona state legislature due
to exposing those folks
and he just gets to check in and get the
absolute top treatment you know it's
part of that two-tier system that we
talk about
this next clip is hilarious we're seeing
the equivalent
of competing temper tantrums happening
right now
right-wing media that's loyal to trump
is having a temper tantrum
as they realize trump's going to leave
office trump lost
joe biden won none of these ridiculous
attempts to steal the election are going
to work so that's one temper tantrum
on the other side meanwhile you have
some trump advisors increasingly having
a temper tantrum
that more and more media are
acknowledging that trump won
you understand the competing temper
tantrums here
and the day before yesterday this came
together
and it was just glorious i mean this is
it this is a pleasure to watch and it
was made even better
by a slight connection delay between the
two people involved and this was a
conversation between
fox business host lou dobbs and
huge who by the way is a huge trumpist
himself
and then radical unhinged extremist
trump advisor
stephen miller so check out this clip
and what it seems like is happening here
is lou dobbs is mad at republicans for
not
standing behind trump and not fighting
more
fighting to steal an election that trump
lost by the way
and stephen miller is mad apparently at
states and governors
when they seem to then start getting mad
at each other
the connection delay makes it even
funnier lou dobbs seems mad at stephen
miller
and it's just a complete fiasco and this
is truly people who have no idea what to
do
they're falling apart like a kid who
missed their nap take a look at this
cans do nothing stephen nothing it's
it's it's it's an outright it's wrong
what's wrong with the republican party
where is the outrage really tens of
millions
tens of millions of pounds
tens of millions of ballots nationwide
no signature checks
no citizenship checks no residency
checks no age checks no criminal record
checks
not even checking if you're alive or
dead now of course what stephen miller
is saying is absurd
no we're not checking if people are
alive you can't vote if you're dead
physically you can't do it no
citizenship check you can't even
register to vote if you're not a citizen
these are the same old tired talking
points
that they keep using and this
conversation kept escalating
as lou dobbs claims republicans have
abandoned donald trump take a look
are we a third world country are we a
banana republic
what does it come to it only legal
balance
from u.s citizens let me tell you what
it is president gets four more years
let me uh and and you know from your
lips to god's ears
uh the reality is that this president
right now
is fighting and let's be straightforward
about it he's
fighting all alone and ted cruz has
stepped up to say he'll argue before the
supreme court
why on god's green earth wouldn't the
white house
jump on it why shouldn't they accept
that right now
and i'll just say this one other thing
though if three state legislatures i
just outlined
one correction i'm not going to let you
do this i'm not going to let you do that
i'm not going to let you do that i
ask a question you and i we're
reasonably smart
and decent fellows they are reasonably
smart and decent
they just want an election that joe
biden won
to be overturned without evidence and
given to the man they worship
these are guys these are recent
reasonably smart and decent people who
just want the democratic process thrown
in the toilet and trump awarded a
victory
they just disagree about how to do it
lou dobbs is mad at republican senators
while i guess stephen miller is mad at
republican governors
but now lou dobbs demands an answer from
stephen miller
why don't you hire ted cruz as a lawyer
to fight this battle
why don't you answer me that's all i'm
asking here stephen
why don't you guys jump and salute ted
cruz
and say yes we want you on the team now
my god this is not a time for
internecine
nonsense on the part of the republican
party which is watching its blood drain
into the streets
because their gut consider how absurd
lou dobbs idea is to hire ted cruz as a
lawyer
to steal the election hire a sitting
senator
to also be a lawyer from the for the
pres it's just a farcical idea
and it's actually funny because lou i
don't know if you saw but lou dobbs did
something there that's rarely done
on right wing media to trump advisers
and trump sycophants
lou dobbs interrupted stephen miller and
said you're not answering the question
so this proves what we suspected which
is they do know
these journalists do know how to do it
but they're choosing not to
unless they don't like the answer lou
dobbs in this case
didn't like the answer so we're seeing
everything in the last few weeks we're
seeing
some rats abandoning the ship and sort
of eating each other on the way out
we're seeing some rats go down with the
ship kaylee mckennany would be an
example of that
um you're seeing people who are going
the direction of sort of like pretending
none of this ever happened
and uh it really is like the best comedy
team
on television you know rudy gets covid
put ted cruz
on the case it's laughable and hilarious
and it will be over soon i'm not here to
tell you help is on the way that's not
my catchphrase
it will be over soon as the catchphrase
that that i'm going with here
we have a voicemail number that number
is 2192davidp
this is really funny so last week
when i was teasing the bonus show
previewing the stories on the bonus show
i had a verbal slip and i called it the
boner show
and we chose not to edit it out because
we don't edit the show we actually
do the show is just we just film it and
that's the show and it was sort of funny
and there were expectedly memes and
there were
songs and remixes and all this different
stuff but there are now lots of callers
who are casually referring to it as the
boner show in voicemails
and that's not even like the main point
of the call and
i have one such call today about that
but this is actually really really
interesting
uh the other day pat and i took the new
york times
dialect quiz i mentioned having friends
from the south who claim i have a new
york accent and sometimes people call
into the show and say i have a boston
accent but i don't have either i didn't
grow up in boston or new york
and i did this new york times dialect
quiz and it came back
saying i have a southern western new
england accent primarily which is
accurate that's exactly where i grew up
and that i have elements of my uh
dialect
in english that are typically from
yonkers new york and pembroke pines
florida
now i hypothesized i wonder
if there is some aspect of what is
sometimes called
the jewish american dialect that would
be centered around yonkers and pembroke
pines that has
kind of that there are traces of it in
my speech and this caller who again
casually refers to the bonus show as the
boner show
has a different explanation for those
elements of my speech take a listen this
is really interesting
hey david i was listening to your bonus
show the other day
and you were talking about how you took
the quiz to determine your dialect
yes and i believe that one of the
pin it pinpointed you to be having a
dialect from the pembroke pines florida
area
well i have an office in pembroke pines
i'm familiar with the area
and i believe you can attributed that to
perhaps your jewish heritage but i would
like to set the record straight on yeah
please because
pembroke fines has a very high hispanic
population
about over 40 percent hispanic primarily
college educated
mostly from south america so i believe
that may be where
that hint of dialect may have come from
so
that is very very interesting and
in fact um if you look at
uh pembroke pi at the yonkers new york
which is the other place where my my
accent has
traces has roots there's also a large
hispanic population
in yonkers so that may be accurate and i
was thinking back you know when i first
moved to the united states i only knew
two words i knew the word stop and i
knew the word blue
and i remember leaving jfk airport and
seeing a stop sign
what are the odds you know five-year-old
me what are the odds that
right away i see a word that i know this
is going to go really really easily it's
going to be great
and of course it was difficult but the
early folks
when i was in school they had you know
sort of like helpers
this is when schools i think were maybe
better funded and there was more
staffing but
some of the other um uh kids who were
learning english
coming from spanish-speaking countries
there were there were sort of like
helpers who
spoke english with accents they were
native spanish speakers who spoke
english with accents
and i wonder my early english exposure
other than mr rogers was my parents who
speak english with an accent
sourced from spanish language and
the helpers at school who would have
that exact same
accent in english having learned english
as a second language so i believe that
this caller
may very much be on to something very
very much beyond to something okay
that's it i went on for a long time but
that's the story
on today's bonus show texas has now sued
four different states over election
results
to try to overturn the election for
donald trump does texas
even have standing to sue other states
we will talk about that on today's
bonus show australia is going to make
facebook and google pay news outlets for
content how will that work
we will discuss it and rudy giuliani i
mean
think about the absurdity of this rudy
giuliani
yesterday went on a rant against
masks and against covid restrictions
from his hospital room where he is being
treated for coronavirus which he caught
by not wearing a mask and traveling
around the country it's
beyond belief all of those stories and
more on today's bonus show get instant
access by becoming a member
at joinpacman.com coupon code available
if you want it
fresh start or get access to the bonus
show by becoming a
patron at patreon.com
show
thanks a lot for watching today's show i
just want to take a second to tell you
about today's sponsors
steadymd lets you maintain a meaningful
long-lasting relationship with a primary
care physician
who you can meet with any time over
phone or video chat you don't need
insurance it's only 99
a month with no other fees or copays
visit steadymd.com
pacman to get started blinkist is the
app that helps you become a more
well-rounded person by letting you read
or listen to an
entire nonfiction book in just 15
minutes you can try it for free
and get 25 off a subscription by going
to blinkist.com
david pakman hydrant is the delicious
fruit drink powder packed with essential
electrolytes for hydration and it's more
cost
effective than expensive sugary sports
drinks to get 25
off go to drinkhydrant.com pacman and
use the code pacman